universe is restricted to a certain
domain and the reason is is because if
we use our horizontal line test say for
example like this it passes the graph at
more than one point which means that the
inverse is not a function okay so if we
want the inverse to be a function we
have to restrict this domain such that
it passes that horizontal line test so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna look
at just this part right here from here
to here so for sine that's going to be
from negative PI over 2 to positive PI
over 2 so that's going to be the part
that we're interested in so when you use
your calculator to find the sine inverse
or the arc sine as it's sometimes called
it's your calculator is only going to
give you an answer from negative 90 to
positive 90 negative PI over 2 to
positive PI over 2 just in this quadrant
here and this quadrant here
if it ends up in the fourth quadrant
it's not going to give you an angle you
know all the way around here between 270
and 360 it's actually going to give it
to you as a negative angle because you
can see you're just going here to the
left negative okay now for cosine again
you can see cosine feels the horizontal
line test right this continues on it's
going to fail that that horizontal line
test but if we restrict it from here to
here okay so that's from 0 to PI ok
we're just looking at this piece of the
graph right there then it passes that
horizontal line test so it does have an
inverse so on the unit circle that would
equate to 0 to PI that would be these
first and second quadrants and then for
tangent again tangent also fails a
horizontal line test but if we just look
at from negative PI over 2 to positive
PI over 2 just this branch right here
just this little part of the graph just
like sine okay if we restrict it from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
then it's a function ok so that's
something to pay attention to but let's
take a look at some problems now so why
would you even need to use the inverse
trigonometric functions well use the
inverse trigonometric functions whenever
you're trying to solve for a missing
angle so say we wanted to find out what
this angle is here what we would do is
we
all right what trig function ties
together opposite side and the
hypotenuse well that's going to be sine
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say sine of theta equals opposite
over hypotenuse we want to get this
angle by itself so we're going to take
the sine inverse of both sides of the
equation
okay to keep it balanced these are
inverses theta equals the sine inverse
of 513 so let's go to our calculator now
let's see what that comes out to in
radians so that comes out to sine
inverse 513 0.39 okay so 0.39 so what
that means is that you're going to be
right about here
Oh point three nine radians okay so
that's that angle right there okay now
let's do some salt some equations now
okay so we found this angle let's solve
some equations we want to find out where
sine equals point eight so what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
arc sine arc sine is the same as this
notation here the sine minus one the
sine inverse arc sine of sine of X
equals the arc sine of point eight okay
so these are inverses we get our angle
by itself let's go to the calculator
again so we're going to take the arc
sine of point eight and we get 0.93 okay
so 0.93 readings now where is 0.93
radians on the unit circle well it's
going to be right about here okay so
that's 0.93 but where else is sine
positive in the second quadrant so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna draw that
same triangle okay the same triangle
this reference angle is 0.93 but
remember when we measure angles we
measure from the positive x-axis
counterclockwise if it's positive so
this is going to be 0.93 this point here
is actually going to be pi minus point
nine three so we went past that point
and we went back so that's going to be
0.93 or pi minus 0.9 3 which is 3 point
1 4 minus 0.9 3 and we can see what that
is 3.14 minus 0.9 3 2 point 2 1 okay so
those are our two answers on the unit
circle so the calculator only gave us
that first answer because it was from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
is in that restricted domain so you have
to realize that your calculator is only
going to give you that one solution it's
up to you to find out where else is sine
positive or where else would that value
be on the unit circle so let's do
another example tangent of x equals 0.2
okay so let's do the tan inverse okay
everybody has their preferred notation
either the minus 1 notation or the arc
notation but we'll just do the tan
inverse of both sides
okay these are inverses so we get ax
equals the tangent inverse of point two
I'll do that on the calculator here okay
we get about point two zero profit ly so
it almost it's almost exactly the same
point one ninety seven point one nine
seven radians okay but all this is
negative point two let's do that again
tangent inverse of negative point two
it's negative point one ninety seven
okay so where is tangent negative
it's negative in the second quadrant and
the fourth quadrant so what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to draw another
unit circle here so we've got negative
point one nine seven so that's going to
be here okay and that's also going to be
here so this reference angle is point
one nine seven ok now depending on the
question how it's phrased they'll say
find all solutions from zero to two pi
so if that's the case we're going this
direction which is a positive angle so
that's going to be PI minus point one
nine seven because we're going past
that's PI which is 180 degrees K minus
the point one nine seven so that's one
solution
the other solution over here we're going
to go actually to PI so we went all the
way around to PI and then we went a
little bit too far so we have to back up
or subtract off the 0.197
so those are your two solutions right
there
so again just make sure that when you're
working with the arc sine or the arc
tangent okay that you're going to get a
solution that's from negative PI over 2
to positive PI over 2 arc cosine you're
going to be from 0 to PI and then what
you want to do is you want to analyze on
the unit circle what other quadrants you
know with that angle occur in and go
ahead and find those solutions as well
all right so this has been a video about
how to work with inverse trig functions
I'll see you in the next video